ça va c'est que les votes chanteur ou
une chanteuse le plus est la plus sexy
la plus sexy franchement j'ai un petit
tout petit peu réfléchi je pense à
alicia keys et beyoncé est en fait c'est
shakira shakira
car
ouais
là
les blagues à chaque fois vous ferez le
chanteur ou la chanteuse ouvrait la
danse
cool d'accord vous c'est chacun à le
débaucher de shakira est mortelle moi je
kiffe est offert chaque héros non mais
vraiment très costaud bout bonsoir le
divino cela le mec le + sexy
sliman bva
ça c'est slimane d'un bail reste comme
ça souvent ah oui à tout ces slips man
siki blon
je vous laisse réfléchir à mon nom mais
je peux réfléchir c'est vexant faudra du
temps ce n'est pas tant ce n'est jamais
bien
jamila elodie frégé dans un box et va
vous donc c'est josette choisy à mon ami
mon malick ba alors il savait que
c'était celle que l'on verra tous tous
les vendredis et voilà sauvé rail balic
et voilà c'est maintenant s'il vient il
est chez lui à montréal à me frapper le
mali qu'on te rappelles tu es non
voyants exact et voilà il s'est tu
quittes venir nous voir et de suez
nouveau chez nous on kiffe côté là voilà
un petit regard c'est justement
capillaire qu'il a passée qui toi pour
toi que tu es moi j'aime bien rihanna
quand même là
c'est pas bon les gars touche l'oubli
c'est pas visibles avant les frères
votre délire pour rien c'est bondé hier
je vous le dirai sept suspects vous avez
aucun délire chantilly sait jamais d'où
cette fois là bas ce qui attend plus il
y en a plein allez vas-y fais toi
plaisir une juste pour voir kelly dans
sa cause
nicki minaj
c'est d'habitude tu le fais mieux
qu'elle
ehpad de sky
l'équipe ce monsieur là bas leur dirais
qu'il est en trois parties non je pense
qu'il rappelle la maxi ted rennais
ouvraient les allées plus face à des
frais quand même pas ta peau le nombre à
ce que là il est en position de snipers
alors vous matching et bonsoir toujours
qui représente les jt de bons choix
ma chanson préférée c'est arianna grande
et 1 m 53 p tits et par la taille grand
départ le talent ch
on vient pas de trouver une utilité
kelly quand même les piscines et servait
à rien mais on décèle qu'il a demandé
une crêpe au sucre
non mais sérieux doit nommer un fossé
mais qui dit ça françois calmez-vous
quand même un bon merci gilles verdez
qui ne restera pas à jésus nous voir
parce que on voudra on va reparler de
joey starr de très bonnes il avait
quelque chose de nous dire donc merci
d'être là beyoncé a comme toujours non
là aussi c'était beyoncé bon bah
franchement entre les deux va mal à
choisir vous la mettez dans la merde
attend il y en a un troisième qui arrive
sur mois prochain moi j'aime bien lyon 2
et je vais pas mentir non plus avec nous
on a fait connaissance en loge il a 20
ans il habite à toulouse
je vais venir à toulouse aller le 9
janvier avec big flo et oli
j'ai pas parce qu'on va faire on va le
faire et alors qu a atteint d'une
maladie génétique rare et évolutive et
en fauteuil électrique tutti fratelli
oui bah on est très content que tu joues
avec nous mais je suis très content
voilà tu vas donner ton avis tu fais
partie de l'équipe
voilà l'équipe était ce un pacte horloge
ça va super a dit la chanteuse que tu
kiffes toit de ou moi c'est le one man
one
enfin
on les règle
on sait mettre aux côtés mais bien et
bien je tape en touche et maxime
chevalier
oui alors accusé comme heidi manuel des
daft punk et ça les daft punk
là encore on les bat pas encore ma lui
qui m'en veulent encore davantage me de
l'opacité on peut tout imaginer derrière
les cadres et take to know pas cité